on vaccinations and a few other top
priorities
for the american people first on
vaccinations
on december 8th i indicated that i hope
to get
100 million shots in people's arms
in my first 100 days we met that goal
last week
by day 58 42 days ahead of schedule
now today i'm setting a second goal and
that is
we will buy my 100th day in office have
administered 200 million
shots in people's arms that's right 200
million shots in
100 days i know it's ambitious
twice our original goal but no other
country in the world has even come
close not even close to what we are
doing
i believe we can do it and today
we made a historic investment in
reaching the hardest hit
and the most vulnerable communities the
highest risk communities
at uh as a consequence of the virus by
investing additional
10 billion dollars in being able to
reach them
i also set a goal before i took office
of getting a majority of schools
in k through 8 fully open
in the first 100 days now thanks to the
enormous amount of work done by
our administration educators parents
local state education officials and
leaders
recent department of education survey
shows that
nearly half of the k-8 schools are open
now
full-time five days a week for in-person
learning
not yet a majority but we're really
close
and i believe in the 35 days left to go
we'll meet that goal as well
as of yesterday more than 100 million
payments of one thousand four hundred
dollars
have gone into people's bank accounts
that's real money in people's pockets
bringing relief instantly almost
and millions more will be getting their
money
very soon one final note
since we passed the american rescue plan
we're starting to see new signs of hope
in our economy since it was passed
a majority a majority of economic
forecasters
have significantly increased their
projections
on the economic growth that's going to
take place this year
they're now projecting it will exceed
six percent a six percent growth in gdp
and just this morning we learned the
number of people
filing for weekly unemployment insurance
fell by nearly 100 000
persons it's the first time in a year
the number has fallen below the
pre-pandemic
high so there are still too many
americans out of work too many families
hurting
and i still have a lot of work to do but
i can say
to you the american people help
is here and hope is on the way
now i'll be happy to take your questions
zeke associated press
thank you mr president you mentioned
your progress on covenant i'd like to
ask you about some of the other
issues uh facing your presidency one of
the defining challenges you face in the
coming months
is how to deliver on your promise to
americans on issues like immigration
reform
gun control voting rights climate change
all of those right now are facing stiff
united opposition from republicans on
capitol hill
how far are you willing to go to achieve
those promises that you made to the
american people
well i'm good look when uh
when i took office i uh
decided that uh it was a fairly basic
simple proposition
and that is i got elected to solve
problems
and the most urgent problem facing the
american people i stated from the outset
was covet 19 and the economic
dislocation for millions and millions of
americans and so that's why i put
all my focus in the beginning for a lot
of problems
but all my focus on dealing with those
particular problems and the other
problems we're talking about
from immigration to guns and the other
things you mentioned
are long-term problems they've been
around a long time
and what we're going to be able to do
god willing
is now begin one at a time to focus on
those as well
and whether it's immigration or guns or
a number of other problems that face the
country but the fundamental problem
is getting people some peace of mind so
they can go to bed at night and not
stare at the ceiling wondering whether
they lost their health insurance
whether they're going to lose some
family member whether they're going to
be in a position where
they're not going to be they're going to
lose their home because they can't pay
their mortgage or the millions of people
are going to get thrown out of their
homes because of
the inability to uh to pay their rent
so we're we're going to move on these
one at a time
try to do as many simultaneous as we can
but
that's the reason why i focused as i
have
and here's the deal i think my
republican colleagues are going to have
to determine
whether or not we want to work together
or they're decide that the way in which
they want to proceed
is to uh is to uh just
decide to divide the country continue
the politics of division
but i'm not going to do that i'm just
going to move forward and take these
things as they come
up mr president can your presidency be a
success if you can't make progress
on those four challenges climate change
immigration reform gun control voting
rights
well i plan on making progress on all of
them but that's going to be for the
american people to decide
i think you know i i doubt whether maybe
you did maybe others did i
i i thought many of you thought there
was no possibility of my getting
the plan i got passed passed without any
republican votes
pretty big deal got passed
growing the economy people's lives are
changing
so let's see what happens all i know
i've been hired to solve problems
to solve problems not create division
uh okay how about
yamiche
thanks so much mr president um you've
said over and over again
that immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
the reason why a lot of immigrants are
coming to this country and entrusting
you with unaccompanied minors
how do you resolve that tension and
how are you choosing which families can
stay which can can go given the fact
that even though
with title 42 there are some families
that are staying and is there a timeline
for when we won't be seeing these
overcrowded facilities
with run by cpb when it comes to
unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whoever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came 28 increase in
children to the border
in my administration 31
in the last year of in 2019 before the
pandemic
in the trump administration it happens
every single solitary year
there is a significant increase the
number of people coming to the border
in the winter months of january february
march
that happens every year in addition to
that
there is a and nobody and by the way
does anybody suggest that there was a 31
percent increase under trump because he
was a nice guy
and he was doing good things at the
border that's not the reason they're
coming
the reason they're coming is that it's
the time they can travel with the least
likelihood of dying on the way because
of the heat in the desert
number one number two they're coming
because
of the circumstances in country
in country the way to deal with this
problem
and i started to deal with it back when
i was the united states senator
i mean vice president for putting
together a bipartisan plan of over 700
million dollars
to do the root causes of why people are
leaving what did trump do
he eliminated that funding he didn't use
it
he didn't do it in addition to that what
he did he dismantle all the elements
that exist to deal with what had been a
problem
and what and has been continued to be a
problem for a long time
he in fact shut down the
the number of beds available he did not
fund hhs to get people to get
the children out of those those border
patrol facilities where they should not
be and not supposed to be more than
a few days a little while but he
dismantled all of that
and so what we're doing now is
attempting to rebuild
rebuild the system that can accommodate
the what is happening today and i'd like
to think
it's because i'm a nice guy but it's not
it's because of what's happened
every year let me say one other thing on
this if you take a look
at the number of people are coming the
vast majority
the overwhelming majority of people
coming to the border crossing are being
sent
back are being sent back
thousands tens of thousands
of people who are who are over
18 years of age and single people
one at a time coming have been sent back
sent home we're sending back the vast
majority of the families that are coming
we're trying to work out now with mexico
their willingness to take
more of those families back but we
that that's what's happening they're not
getting across the border and those who
are coming across the border who are
unaccompanied children
were moving rapidly to try to put in
place what was dismantled as i said
for example of all the children are
coming across the border
over 70 percent are either 16 or 17
years old
we're not talking about people ripping
babies from mother's arms or a little
three-year-old
standing on the border less than i think
it's one and a half percent
fall in the category of the very young
so what we're doing is we're providing
for the space
again to be able to get these kids out
of the border patrol
facilities which no child no one should
be
in any longer than 72 hours and today
i went to for example i used all the
resources available to me
went to the defense department and and
this the secretary of defense has just
made available
fort bliss 5 000 beds
be immediately available 5 000 beds in
the texas border
so we're building back up the capacity
that should have been maintained and
built upon
that trump dismantled it's going to take
time
and the other thing we're doing i might
add am i giving you too long an answer
because if you don't want the detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there in new york my
follow-up question
is um one if you could talk a little bit
about which families why they're being
allowed to say
what the families that are being allowed
to stay why they're being allowed to say
in addition to that
when it comes to the filibuster which is
what zeke was asking about
there's immigration is a big issue of
course with when it relates to the
filibuster but there's also republicans
who are passing
bill after bill trying to restrict
voting rights
chuck schumer is calling it an
existential threat to democracy
why not back a filibuster rule that at
least gets around
issues including voting rights or
immigration jim clyburn
someone of course who you know very well
has backed the idea of a filibuster rule
when it comes to civil rights and voting
rights
well look i'm going to deal with all
those problems
the question is the priorities as they
come and land on my plate let's go to
the first question you asked
the first of the second questions you've
asked and that is
what about dealing with families why are
not
some not going back because mexico
is refusing to take them back
they're saying they won't take them back
not all of them we're in negotiations
with the president of mexico i think
we're going to see that change
they should all be going back all be
going back
the only people were not going to let
sitting there on the other side of the
rio grande by themselves with no help
are children and what we're doing there
and it's important point to understand i
know you understand it i don't mean to
say it that way
important point to focus on the vast
majority of people under the age of 18
come to the united states
come with a telephone number on the on a
wristband
or come with a telephone number in their
pocket in the united states
a mother a father a close relative a
grandmom or grandpa
what's happening before is it's taking
literally
weeks and weeks and maybe even months
before anybody pick up the phone and
call
to see if there really was someone there
well we've set up a system now
where within 24 hours there's a phone
call made
as that person that child crosses the
border
and then a verification system being put
in places
as of today to determine quickly whether
or not
that is a trafficker being called or
that is actually
a mom a dad and or a close relative
they're establishing that right off the
bat if it in fact is
mom or dad dad says to take the extreme
case i got a birth certificate
then guess what we're getting that kid
directly to
that parent immediately and so
that's going to reduce significantly
there's two ways to reduce
child populations in circumstances that
are not acceptable like
being held at a border patrol station
one is to get them to the place where
they
have a relative and set a date as to
when a hearing can be held
the second way to do it is put them in a
health and human services facility that
were occupying now
both licensed beds around the country
that exist
as well as for example federal resources
like fort bliss
to get them safely in a place
where they can be taken care of while
their fate is determined
filibuster fulfill the filibuster um you
know
with regard to the filibuster i believe
we should go back to a position of the
filibuster that existed
just when i came to the united states
senate 120 years ago
and that is that it used to be required
for the filibuster
and i i had a card on this i was going
to give you the statistics but you
probably know them
uh that it used to be that uh
the that well from between 1917 and 1971
the filibuster existed
there were a total of 58 motions
to break a filibuster that whole time
last year alone there were five
times that many so it's being abused in
a gigantic way
and for example it used to be you had to
stand there
and talk and talk and talk and talk
until you collapsed
and guess what people got tired of
talking and tired of collapsing
filibusters broke down and were able to
break the filibuster get a quorm and
vote
so i strongly support moving in that
direction in addition to
having an open mind about dealing with
certain things that are
are just elemental to the functioning of
our democracy
like the right to vote like the basic
right to vote
we've amended the filibuster in the past
but here's the deal
as you observed i'm a fairly practical
guy
i want to get things done i want to get
them done
consistent with what we promised the
american people
and in order to do that in a 50-50
senate
we've got to get to the place where i
get 50 votes
so that the vice president united states
can break the tie or i get 51 votes
without her
and so i'm going to say something
outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things
done in the united states senate so the
best way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done and if
we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about okay
um hang on uh
sorry oh sing me
miss kim
thank you mr president um to follow up
on the filibuster
so do you believe it should take 60
votes to end a filibuster on legislation
or 51
if we could end it with 51 we would have
no problem
you're going to have to the existing
rule uh
it's going to be hard to get a
parliamentary ruling that allows
50 votes to end the filibuster the the
existence of a filibuster
um but um
it's not my expertise and what the
parliamentary rules and how to get there
are but
our preoccupation with the filibuster is
totally legitimate
but in the meantime we've got a lot we
can do while we're talking about what
we're going to do
about the filibuster um
let me get here okay
cecilia vega
i'd like to circle back to immigration
please uh
you just listed the reasons that people
are coming uh
talking about in-country problems saying
that it happens every year
you blame the last administration sir i
just got back
last night from a reporting trip to the
border where i met
nine-year-old jose who walked here from
honduras
by himself along with another little boy
he had that phone number on him
and we were able to call his family his
mother
says that she sent her son to this
country because she believes
that you are not deporting unaccompanied
minors like her son that's why she sent
him a loan from honduras
so sir you blame the last administration
but is your messaging in saying that
these children are
and will be allowed to stay in this
country and work their way through this
process
encouraging families like joe says to
come
well look
the idea that i'm gonna say
which i would never do if an
unaccompanied child ends up at the
border we're just gonna let them starve
to death and stay on the other side
no previous administration did that
either except trump
i'm not going to do it i'm not going to
do it
that's why i've asked the vice president
united states yesterday
to be the lead person on dealing with
focusing on the fundamental reasons why
people leave honduras guatemala el
salvador
in the first place it's because of
earthquakes
floods it's because of lack of food it's
because of
gang violence it's because of a whole
range of things
that when i was vice president had the
same obligation to deal with
unaccompanied children
i was able to get it slowed up
significantly by working with the heads
of state of those
communities to do things like in one of
the major cities
reason people were leaving is they
couldn't walk in the street because they
were getting
their kids were getting beat up or shot
or gang violence
well what i was able to do is not give
money to
the head of state because so many are
corrupt but i was able to say okay you
need lighting in the streets to change
things
i'll put the lighting in we got a
contractor
we got the type of lighting we paid
directly the contractor did not go
through the government
and violent crime significantly was
reduced in that city
fewer people sought to leave when this
hurricane
occurred two hurricanes instead of us
going down and helping
in a major way so that people would not
have a reason to want to leave
in the first place because they didn't
have housing or water
or sustenance we did nothing
we're going to do a lot in our
administration
we're going to be spending that 700 plus
million dollars a year
to change the life and circumstances of
why people leave in the first place
that mother did not sit around with on
the kitchen table
and say you know i got a great idea why
i'm going to make sure my son get taken
care of
is i'm going to put him how old was he
or she
he's 9. i also met a 10 year old a a
nine-year-old i'm going to send him on a
thousand mile journey across the desert
and up to the united states
because i know joe biden's a nice guy
and he'll take care of him
what a desperate act to have to take
the circumstances must be horrible so we
can do
something about that that's what the
vice president is going to be doing
what i did when president obama asked me
to come and deal i was in
i was in turkey at the time he said you
got to come home and take care of this
so we put together a plan and it had an
impact
and so the question here is whether how
we go ahead and do this what we do
there's no easy answer
quick follow if i may do you want to see
these unaccompanied minors
staying in this ch this country or
should they be deported eventually
well the judgment has to be made whether
or not in this young man's case he has a
mom at home
there's a overwhelming reason why he'd
be putting a plane and flown back to his
mom
follow sir you mentioned uh
circumstances that must be
horrific the customs and border
protection facility in donna texas i was
there
is that 1556 capacity
right now with mostly unaccompanied
minors there are kids that are sleeping
on floors
they are packed into these pods i've
spoken to lawyers who say that they
some of these children have not seen the
sun in days what's your reaction
what is your reaction to these images
that have come out from that particular
facility
is what's happening inside acceptable to
you
and when is this going to be fixed
that's a serious question right
is it acceptable to me come on that's
why
we're going to be moving a thousand of
those kids out quickly
that's why i got fort bliss opened up
that's why i've been working from the
moment
this started to happen to try to find
additional access
for children to be able to safely not
just children but particularly children
to be able to safely be housed while we
follow through on the rest of what's
happening
that is totally unacceptable
um ken
thank you mr president i want to ask you
about afghanistan
you face a may first deadline for the
withdrawal
of u.s troops from that country
as a candidate in foreign affairs you
wrote
that it is past time to end these
forever wars
can you commit to the american people
that by may 2nd
the u.s will no longer have forces
in afghanistan the answer is that
it's going to be hard to meet the may
one deadline
just in terms of tactical reasons it's
hard to get those
troops out so what we've been doing what
i've been doing
and what secretary blinken has been
doing
has been we've been meeting with our
allies
those other nations that have nato
allies who have
troops in afghanistan as well and
and if we leave we're going to do so in
a safe and
orderly way we're in consultation i said
with our allies and partners
and how to proceed and secretary blinken
is meeting in brussels this week with
our nato
allies particularly those who have
forces there
and general austin is just met with
kyani and i'm waiting for the briefing
on that he is the
the the leader quote in afghanistan and
kabul
and uh there's a un-led process that's
beginning
uh shortly on how to mechanically
get people how to end this war but
it is not my intention to stay there for
a long time
but the question is how and in what
circumstances do we
meet that agreement that was made by
president trump to
leave under a deal that looks like it's
not being able to be worked out to begin
with
how how's that done but we are not
staying
a long time
do you think it's possible that we will
leave the question is
when we leave sorry do you believe
though it's possible we could have
troops there next year
i i i can't picture that being the case
okay uh kristen
thank you very much mr president given
the conditions that were just laid out
at the migrant facilities
at the u.s border will you commit to
allowing journalists
to have access to the facilities that
are
overcrowded moving forward i will commit
when my plan very shortly is underway
to let you have access to not just them
but other facilities as well
be able to have access to the facilities
we've obviously been allowed to be
inside
one but we haven't seen the facilities
in which children are packed together
to really give the american people a
chance to see that will you commit to
transparency on this issue i will commit
to transparency
and as soon as i am in a position to be
able to implement what we're doing
right now and one of the reasons i
haven't gone down
i've all my my chief folks have gone
down as i don't want to become
the issue i don't want to be you know
bringing
all the secret service and everybody
with me to get in the way
so this is being set up and you'll have
full access to everything once we get
this thing moving
okay just to be clear how soon will that
be mr president
i don't know to be clear
for everything that's happening at the
border now i hear you talking a lot
about the past administration
you decided to roll back some of those
policies did you move
too quickly to roll back what i'm sorry
policies
did you move too quickly to roll back
some of the executive orders of your
predecessor first of all
all the policies are underway were not
helping at all
did not slow up the amount of
immigration and as many people coming
and rolling back the policies of
separating children from their
from their mothers i make no apology for
that rolling back the policies of
remain in mexico sitting on the edge of
the rio grande and the muddy
circumstance with not enough to eat but
i make no apologies for that
i make no apologies for ending programs
that did not exist
before trump became president
that have an incredibly negative impact
on
the law international law
as well as on human dignity and so i
make no apologies for that
to ask you about foreign policy mr
president overnight
we learned that north korea tested two
ballistic missiles what if any actions
will you take and
what is your red line on north korea
let me say that number one
u.n resolution 1718 was violated by
those particular missiles that were
tested
number one we're consulting with our
allies
and partners and
there will be responses if they choose
to escalate
we will respond accordingly but i'm also
prepared
for some form of diplomacy
but it has to be conditioned upon
the end result of denuclearization
so uh um
that's what we're doing right now
consulting with our allies just
very quickly you only got another hour
now okay diplomacy can you define what
you mean
and former president obama warned the
incoming
president trump that north korea was
the top foreign policy issue that he was
washing
is that how you assess the crisis in
north korea yes
okay hang on a second here kristen uh
nancy cbs
you very much mr president i want to go
back to voting rights
and as yamiche mentioned republican
legislatures across the country
are working to pass bills that would
restrict voting particularly
democrats fear impacting minority voters
and young voters the very people who
helped to get you
elected in november are you worried
that if you don't manage to pass
voting rights legislation that your
party is going to lose seats and
possibly lose control
of the house and the senate in 2022.
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
it's sick deciding in some states that
you cannot
bring water to people standing in line
waiting to vote deciding that
you're going to end voting at five
o'clock when working people
are just getting off work deciding that
there will be no absentee ballots under
the most
rigid circumstances it's all designed
and i'm going to spend my time
doing three things one trying to figure
out how to
pass the legislation passed by the house
number one number two educating the
american public
the republican voters i know
find this despicable republican voters
the folks out in the outside this white
house
i'm not talking about the elected
officials
i'm talking about voters voters
and so i'm convinced that we'll be able
to stop this because it is the most
pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
i mean this is gigantic what they're
trying to do
and it cannot be sustained and do
everything on my power along with my
friends and their house and the senate
to keep that from uh
from becoming the law is there anything
else
you can do about it besides passing
legislation
the answer is yes but i'm not going to
lay out a strategy
in front of the whole world and you now
and
then on a related note have you decided
whether you are going to run for
reelection
in 2024 you haven't set up a re-election
campaign yet as your predecessor had by
this time
my friend said i need to need it to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
have you have you oh and answer is yes
my plan is to run for reelection that's
my expectation
and then on on one other note on
bipartisanship your old friend
mitch mcconnell says you have only
spoken to each other once
since you took office and that you have
moved far
left since taking office do you see it
the same way he does
have you rejected bipartisanship no i
haven't at all but meeting
when's the last time a president invited
the opposite party down
at least a half a dozen times to talk
about issues everything from
how we work we're working with a group
with 20
members of the senate right now in-house
on how we
re-establish our ability to make
computer chips and how we get ahead of
the game
how we can work together we're working
together on a bunch of things but look
i know mitch well mitch knows me well i
would expect mitch to say exactly what
he said
but this is a matter of making sure that
i would like republican
elected republican support but what i
know i have now is i have
electoral support from republican voters
republican voters agree with what i'm
doing
and so unless mitch says the last thing
i did this
last piece of legislation is so far left
well then you ought to take a look at
his party
over 50 of them must be over that edge
as well
because they support what i did
okay where am i here
let me see caitlin
thank you very much mr president i have
a question for you but first i'd like to
follow up on
a question from yamiche and that's on
the phone that counts as a question but
go ahead
okay i'll make it quick no no you can't
uh
regarding the filibuster at john lewis's
funeral president barack obama
said he believed the filibuster was a
relic of the jim crow era
do you agree yes if not why not abolish
it if it's a relic of the jim crow era
successful electoral politics is the art
of possible
let's figure out how we can get this
done
and move in the direction of
significantly
changing the abuse of even the
filibuster rule
first it's been abused from the time it
came into being
by an extreme way in the last
20 years let's deal with the abuse first
you're moving closer to eliminating the
filibuster is that correct
i answered your question you also just
made some news by saying that you are
going to run for re-election
i said that is my expectation so is that
a yes that you are running for
re-election
look i'm i don't know where you guys
come from man i've never been able to
travel i'm a great respecter of fate
i've never been able to plan four and a
half three and a half years ahead for
certain
and if you do if you do run will vice
president harris be on your ticket
i would fully expect that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't i have no idea
i have no idea but it'll be a republican
party do you
i know you don't have to answer my
question but i mean you know do you i
mean look this is
the way i view things i become a great
respecter of fate in my life
i set a goal of this that's in front of
me to get things done
for the people i care most about which
are hard-working decent american people
of getting really having it stuck to
them
i want to change the paradigm i want to
change the paradigm
we start to reward work not just wealth
i want to change the paradigm if you
notice then you find it kind of
interesting that
my republican friends were worried about
that
the cost and the taxes that had to be
had if there is any tax to be had as
they talk about it
and dealing with the the act that we
just passed
which puts money in people's pockets
ordinary people
do you hear them complain when they
passed close to two trillion dollar
trump tax cut of 83 percent going to the
top
one percent do you talk about that at
all
i love the fact that they found this
whole idea of
concern about the federal budget
it's kind of amazing when the federal
budget is saving people's lives
they don't think it's such a good idea
when the federal budget is feathering
the nest of the wealthiest americans
90 of the fortune 500 companies making
billions of dollars not paying a cent in
taxes
reducing taxes to a point that
people who are making you know if you're
a husband and wife
a school teacher and a cop you're paying
at a higher rate than the average person
making a
billion dollars a year is
something's wrong their newfound concern
i'm concerned look i meant what i said
when i ran and a lot of you still think
i'm wrong and i
respect that i said i'm running for
three reasons
to restore the soul dignity honor
honesty transparency
to the american political system
two to rebuild the backbone of this
country
the middle class hardworking people and
people struggling
in the middle class they built america
and unions built them
the third reason i said i was running
was to unite the country
and generically speaking all of you said
no you can't do that
well i've not been able to unite the
congress but i've been uniting the
country
based on the polling data
we have to come together we have to
so from my perspective you know it's uh
to me it's about just
you know getting out there putting one
foot in front of the other and just
trying to make things better for people
just hard-working people people get up
every morning and just want to figure
out
how to put food in the table for their
kids to be able to have a little bit of
breathing room
being able to have make sure that they
go to bed not staring to the ceiling
because my dad didn't wonder whether
since he didn't have health insurance
what happens if mom gets sick or he got
sick
these are basic things basic things
and i'm of the view that the vast
majority of people
including registered republicans by and
large
share that that that same that same view
that same
sense of what is uh you know what's
appropriate
justin justin sink bloomberg
uh thanks mr president i want to ask
about your relationship with china now
that you've been on
office for a couple months there's
obviously the meeting in alaska that
was a little theatrical and there's the
continued human rights abuses so today
i'm wondering
are you more likely than you were when
you came into office to maintain
tariffs on china are you considering
banning
imports of forced labor products and
would you consider cutting off u.s
investment or chinese access to
international payment systems look uh
they're each specifically legitimate
questions
but they only touch
a smidgen of what the relationship with
china really is about
i've known xi jinping for a long time
allegedly by the time i left office as
vice president i had spent more time
with xi jinping than any world leader
had
because president obama and the chinese
president who
decided we should get to know one
another since it was inappropriate
for the president united states to spend
time with the vice president of another
country
but it was obvious he was going to
become the new leader of china
so i spent hours upon hours with him
alone with an interpreter my interpreter
and his
going into great detail and very very
straightforward
doesn't have a democratic with a small d
bone in his body
but he's a smart smart guy he's one of
the guys
like putin who thinks that autocracy is
the wave of the future democracy can't
function in an ever com
an ever complex world so
when i was elected and he called to
congratulate me
i think to the surprise of the china
experts who were
his people on a call as well as mine
listening
we had a two-hour conversation
for two hours and
we made several things clear to one
another
i made it clear to him again what i've
told them in person on several occasions
that we're not looking for confrontation
although we know there will be steep
steep competition
two that will have strong competition
but will insist that china play by the
international rules
fair competition fair practice is fair
trade
thirdly in order to compete effectively
i indicated
that we're going to deal with china
effectively and we're going to need
three things to do that
telling our people first we're going to
invest in american workers in american
science
i said that all through the campaign i
say it again and we're
i'm setting up my administration to be
able to do that which is that
you know back in the 60s we used to
invest a little over two percent of our
entire
entire gdp in pure research and
investment in science
today it's 0.7 percent i'm going to
change that
we're going to change that the future
lies in who can
in fact own the future as it relates to
technology quantum computing a whole
range of things
including the medical fields and so
what i'm going to do is make sure we
invest
closer to two percent one of the reasons
why
i've set up the the p
ab the president's board with scientists
and like again
is we're going to invest in medical
research
cancer alzheimer's diabetes the things
industries of the future artificial
intelligence quantum computing
biotech and we're going to make real
investments china is out investing us
by a long shot because their plan is to
own that future
the third the second thing we're going
to do is we're going to reestablish our
alliances and i've been very clear with
him
it's not anti-chinese and
we've talked about it i want to make
sure that
for example later today after this as a
matter of fact shortly after this
um which is fine we've been going close
to an hour
i'm happy go go longer but
one of the things that i'm going to be
doing i'm going to be speaking with
27 heads of state in europe
and very shortly i think in the next
hour so i don't know the exact time
and uh earlier this month and apparently
it got the chinese attention that's not
why i did it
i met with our allies and how we're
gonna hold china accountable in the
region
australia india japan the united states
the so-called quad
because we have to have
democracies working together
before too long i'm going to have i'm
going to invite
an alliance of democracies to come here
to discuss the future
and so we're going to make it clear that
in order to deal with these things
we are going to hold china accountable
to follow the rules
follow the rules whether it relates to
the
south china sea or the north china sea
or the agreement made on taiwan
or a whole range of other things and the
third thing
and the thing that i i admire about
dealing with she
is he understands he makes no no
pretense about not
understanding what i'm saying anymore i
knew him i pointed out to him no leader
can
be sustained in his position or her
position unless they represent the
values of the country
and i said as and mr president as i've
told you before
americans value the notion of freedom
america values human rights we don't
always live up to our expectations but
it's a value system
we are founded on that principle and as
long as you
and your country continues to so
blatantly violate human rights
we are going to continue in an
unrelenting way to call through the
attention of the world
and make it clear make it clear what's
happening
and he understood that i made it clear
that no american president
at least one did but no american
president ever
backed down from speaking out of what's
happening to the uyghurs
what's happening in hong kong what's
happening in
in in country that's who we are
the moment a president walks away from
that as the last one did
is the moment we began to lose our
legitimacy around the world
it's who we are so i
see stiff competition with
china china has an overall goal
and i don't criticize them for the goal
but they have an overall goal to become
the leading country in the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
because united states is going to
continue to grow
and expand all right just to follow up
on the meeting of democracies is that
where you
expect in a multilateral way to make
these decisions about
uh sanctions or no that's not what makes
decisions that's where i make sure we're
all the same page
all the same page look i predict to you
your children or grandchildren are going
to be doing their
doctoral thesis on the issue of
who succeeded autocracy or democracy
because that is what is at stake
not just with china look around the
world
we're in the midst of a fourth
industrial revolution
of enormous consequence will there be
middle class
how will people adjust to these
significant changes
in science and technology the
environment
how will they do that and our democracy
is equipped
because all the people get to speak to
compete
it is clear absolutely clear
and most of the scholars i dealt with at
penn agree with me
around the country that this is a battle
between
the utility of democracies in the 21st
century
and autocracies if you notice
you don't have russia talking about
communism anymore
it's about an autocracy
demand decisions made by
a leader of a country that's what's at
stake here we've got to prove democracy
works mr president sorry i know you have
another chance to address
the tragedies in georgia and colorado
you had said to stay tuned for actions
that you might take on gun control
wondering if you've made a decision
either about sending the
manufacturer liability bill that you
promised on day one to capitol hill
or executive actions like going after
ghost guns
or giving money to cities and states to
battle gun control
all the above it's a matter of timing
as you've all observed
successful presidents better than me
have been successful in large part
because they know how to time what
they're doing
order it decide priorities
what needs to be done the next major
initiative is
and i'll be announcing it friday in
pittsburgh in detail
is to rebuild
the infrastructure both physical and
technological infrastructure in this
country
so that we can compete and create
significant numbers of really good
paying jobs really good paying jobs
and some of you have been around long
enough to know
that used to be a great republican goal
initiative
i still think the majority of the
american people
don't like the fact that we are now
ranked what 85th in the world in
infrastructure i mean
look the future rests on whether or not
we have
the best airports that can accommodate
air travel ports that you can get out of
quickly
so businesses decide some of you when
you're if you're ever local reporters
and you found your governor or mayor
trying to attract business to your
community what's the first thing the
business asked
what's the closest access access to an
interstate highway
how far am i from freight rail
is the water is the water available is
enough water available for me to conduct
my business
all the things that relate to
infrastructure we have
somewhere i i asked the staff to write
it down for me and they did
not for this but for a longer discussion
we have somewhere in terms of
infrastructure
we have we rank 13th globally in
infrastructure
china is investing three times more in
infrastructure than the united states is
bridges more than one third of our
bridges
231 thousand of them need repairs
some are physical safety risks or
preservation work
one in five miles of our highways and
major roads are in poor condition
that's 186 000 miles of highway
aviation 20 of all flights
20 of all flights weren't on time
resulting in 1.5
million hours lost in production
6 to 10 million homes in america
still have lead pipes servicing their
water lines
we have over a hundred thousand
wellheads that are not
capped leaky methane
what are we doing and by the way
we can put as many pipe fritters
and miners and us to work capping those
wells
at the same price that they were charged
to dig those wells
so i i just find it um
frustrating frustrating talk about
last point i'll make in the
infrastructure and i apologize for
spending more time on it but is that
if you think about it
[Music]
it's the place where we will be able to
significantly
increase american productivity at the
same time providing
really good jobs for people
but we can't build back to what they
used to be
we have to build the environments are
global warming's already done
significant damage
the roads that used to be above the
water level
didn't have to worry about where the
drainage was
now you got to rebuild them three feet
higher because it's not going to go back
to what it was before only get worse
unless we stop it there's so
much we can do look at all the schools
in america most of you live in the
washington area now
but in your home towns i don't know
where you're all from
how many schools where the kids can't
drink the water out of the fountain
how many schools are still in a position
where there's asbestos
how many schools in america we're
sending our kids to
don't have adequate ventilation how many
homes buildings office complexes
are wasting billions of barrels of oil
over time because they can't hold in
the heat or the air conditioning
because this leaks through the windows
that are so porous
and the connections it's amazing
so there's so much we can do that's good
stuff
makes people healthier and creates good
jobs
and uh i think that i got one more
question here
and janet from univision
thank you mr president we too have been
reporting at the border and just like
cecilia we ran into a pair of siblings
who came in on monday
were detained by cbp had the phone
number for their mother who lives in the
u.s
we have contacted the mother that's the
only way they know her kids are here
because cbp today
thursday has not contacted that mother
so when can we expect your promise of
things getting better
with contacting and expediting well
they're already getting better but
they're going to get
real they're going to a whole hell of a
lot better real quick and we're going to
hear some people
leaving okay we can get this
done we're going to get it done i had a
long meeting with the entire
team and several cabinet level officers
the other night
we're going to be moving within the next
within the next week over a hundred
thousand i mean
a thousand people out of uh
the border patrol into safe secure
beds and facilities we're going to
significantly ramp up we're already out
there contacting
everyone from getting some of the
employees at hhs there's a lot of them
doing other things and move them into
making those calls
we're in the process of rearranging and
providing for the personnel
needed to get that done but i admire the
fact that
you were down there you're making the
calls yourself
it's real the next thing has to happen
though as you well know
has to happen we have to be some
certitude that this
is the actually mom dad or whomever
and there's ways to do that there's ways
to do that a little bit like determining
whether or not
you got the right code for your credit
card uh you know
what what was your dog's name kind of
thing i'm being a bit facetious but not
really
and also seeking harder data from dna
to uh to birth certificates which takes
longer
so i want to do this as as
quickly as humanly possible and as
safely as possible
well no treating the root cause it
causes in latin america doesn't change
things overnight
how do you realistically and physically
keep these families from coming to the
us
when things will not get better in their
countries right away
well i i can't guarantee that but i know
you know that old thing the journey of a
thousand miles starts with the first
step
you know as well as i do you cover it
you have seri it's not like somebody's
sitting on a
hand you table in guatemala i mean in in
somewhere in mexico or
in guadalupe saying i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give it to
a coyote
have them take our kids across the
border into the desert where they don't
speak the language
won't that be fun let's go
that's not how it happens people don't
want to leave
when my great-grandfather got in a
coffin ship in the irish sea
expectation was was he was going to live
long enough
on that ship to get to the united states
of america but they left because what
the brits had been doing
they were in real real trouble they
didn't want to leave
but they had no choice so you've got we
can't
i can't guarantee we're going to solve
everything but i can guarantee we can
make everything
better we can make it better
we can change the lives of so many
people and the other thing i want to
point out to you
and i hope you point out i realize it's
much more heart-wrenching and it is
to deal with a five and six and
seven-year-old but you went down there
and you saw the vast
majority of these children 70 percent
are 16 years old
17 years old mostly males doesn't make
it
doesn't make it good bad or different
but the idea
that we have tens of thousands of kids
in these god-awful facilities that are
really little babies crying all night
there's some that's true
that's what we got to act and yesterday
i asked
my team both the director of the two
agencies as well as others
i asked them what would they in fact and
i asked their opinion because they're
the experts but i said
focus on the most vulnerable immediately
but there's no reason why in the next
month as people cross the border that
phone
call can't be made in the first 48 hours
and began i may ask one last question
have you had any talks with
senate republicans who are threatening
this administration with not considering
the immigration legislation that was
passed in the house until the situation
at the border
has been resolved no because i know they
have to posture for a while
they sort of got to get out of their
system
this is a um
but i i'm ready to work with any
republican
who wants to help solve the problem
or make make the situation better but
folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
thank you
wow
foreign